[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Sirin guten Abend ihnen allen mehr
zum WM halbfinal-fieber das ja schon
grassiert später mit dir Christine noch
einmal schlafen guten Abend und hier
sind unsere Themen an diesem Montag
noch mehr Korruption bei der EU die
bekannten Fälle könnten nur der Anfang
sein fürchten Parlamentarier es gibt
weitere Durchsuchungen
zweite Hinrichtung im Iran im
Zusammenhang mit den Protesten lässt das
Regime einen 23-jährigen Demonstranten
töten die EU verschärft ihre Sanktionen
und Rettungshelfer schlagen Alarm immer
öfter werden sie für Bagatellen
angefordert sind überlastet zu wenige
und im schlimmsten Fall die
entscheidenden Minuten zu spät
[Musik]
auch heute wieder neue Enthüllungen und
weitere Durchsuchungen im EU-Parlament
in der schwählenden Korruptionsaffäre
gibt es jeden Tag neue entlarvende
Details das politische Brüssel ist
geschockt und versucht den Skandal
aufzuarbeiten eine Gruppe um die
vizeparlamentspräsidentin KI soll gegen
sehr viel Geld versucht haben Politik im
Sinne Katas zu beeinflussen zur
politischen Diskussion im EU-Parlament
gleich zunächst Gunner Krüger über das
was bisher über die Affäre bekannt ist
Brüssel Europa-Parlament die
Abgeordneten sind den Straßburg aber die
Polizei war da durchsuchte ein Büro
versiegelte weitere und beschlagnahmte
Computer
der Umfang ist der erheblich es geht um
Korruption Geldwäsche kriminelle
Organisation auf europäischer Ebene
vielmehr sagt Belgiens
Staatsanwaltschaft nicht doch Medien
berichten etwa von Markt tarabella der
belgische Sozialdemokrat war mal
scharfer catter Kritiker zuletzt meinte
er ist einmal gut mit Katha
diese einseitigen negativen Äußerungen
über Kata sind für die künftige
Entwicklung der Rechte im LED schädlich
zur Durchsuchung bei ihm sagte die
Justiz macht ihren Job ich habe nichts
zu verbergen Eva kaii noch
Vizepräsidentin bleibt inhaft ihr Vater
kommt frei die Polizei hatte ihn
festgenommen als er dieses Hotel verließ
den Koffer voll Geld die eu-botschaft
von Katar twittert jede Verbindung mit
diesen Vorwürfen entbehrt jeder
Grundlage und beruhta Fehlinformationen
die kommissionspräsidentin zeigte sich
am Mittag besorgt
ich schlage vor eine unabhängige
ethikstelle einzurichten zuständig für
alle EU-Institutionen andere wollen das
Transparenzregister auf
drittstaatenausweiten die
Sozialdemokraten Zweifeln am nutzen wir
haben hier einen Fall dass wir wirklich
jemanden haben der kriminelle Energie
hat der würde ja auch niemals
reinschreiben ins transparente gehen ich
habe 600.000 Euro von Katar bekommen es
ist die Suche nach Lösungen bevor das
ganze Ausmaß des Skandals bekannt ist
ja und inzwischen gibt es auch schon
erste Stimmen aus dem Europaparlament
die die Bundesregierung auffordern die
gaslieferverträge mit Cutter zu
überprüfen catter selbst weiß der wie
eben gehört die Vorwürfe energisch
zurück aber welche Konsequenzen sind
nötig wie weiter nach diesen
Enthüllungen das war heute großes Thema
bei der EU ultra berichtet
70 Jahre europäische Demokratie der
stolze Satz steht noch an der Fassade
vor wenigen Wochen feierten sie den 70
geburtstag des EU-Parlaments und nun
lastet der Vorwurf der Bestechlichkeit
auf den Abgeordneten das Parlament gibt
sich kämpferisch
zeigt euch nicht das Europäische
Parlament wird angegriffen die
europäische Demokratie wird angegriffen
vor allem die europäischen
Sozialdemokraten von S&D stehen im Fokus
aus ihren Reihen kommen die Verdächtigen
und die Festgenommenen
Problem ist ich glaube das systemisches
Problem der Angriff Katars das
Europa-Parlament zieht Konsequenzen die
angedachte Visa Erleichterung für
cataris die nach Europa reisen wollen
sind wohl vom Tisch
es ist so dass ich nicht davon ausgehe
das total in den nächsten Jahren
irgendeine Chance haben sollte eine
dieser Liberalisierung zu bekommen erste
Abgeordnete stellen nun das Gasabkommen
zwischen Deutschland und Katar in frage
ich finde es an die schwer vorstellbar
dass wir
Lieferverträge eingehen dass wir neue
Abhängigkeiten Schaffen von Staaten die
die international so agieren
einer freut sich über den Skandal Viktor
Orban der ungarische Regierungschef
selbst von der EU wegen Korruption
kritisiert wirft er dem EU-Parlament auf
Twitter Scheinheiligkeit vor
man versucht die Situation auszunutzen
aber ich denke an die Menschen in Ungarn
überhaupt niemanden haben der sie vor
Korruption schützt
heute leer Eva kaii die Vizepräsidentin
setzt in Untersuchungshaft
und alle fragen sich ob da noch mehr
kommt
da ist richtig viel Musik drin Isabel
Schäfers ist für uns in Straßburg Isabel
du stehst im Europaparlament wie war die
Atmosphäre heute und wie sind die
gemachten Ankündigungen zu werten
ja also hier im Europaparlament ist
schon eine deutliche Anspannung und auch
Fassungslosigkeit zu spüren heute
eigentlich ist montags eher so ein
Anreisetag ohne große Themen aber heute
war hier schon eine sehr ernste und
konzentrierte Stimmung die
Parlamentspräsidentin hat dann ja zu
Beginn auch gleich eine sehr klare
Botschaft verkündet wie wir gerade
gehört haben hat sie von einem Angriff
auf die ganze europäische Demokratie
gesprochen und es wurden auch sehr
schnelle Konsequenzen angekündigt so
soll etwa Eva kaii auch ähm ihres Amtes
als Vizepräsidentin enthoben werden und
das vielleicht sogar schon morgen was
auffällig ist wenn man mit den
Abgeordneten verschiedener Fraktionen
heute gesprochen hat ist das alle
betonen das ist jetzt nicht um
Parteipolitik geht sondern um
schonungslose Aufklärung wie konnte es
dazu kommen und was kann man künftig
dagegen tun und das zeigt auf der einen
Seite das hier tatsächlich eine riesige
Bestürzung vorhanden ist aber das zeigt
auf der anderen Seite auch das ist jetzt
hier um Schadensbegrenzung geht weil
durch diesen Skandal ist das Image das
gesamten Parlament jetzt beschädigt
danke nach Straßburg Isabel und zur
Korruptionsaffäre gleich auch ein ZDF
heute live mit EU-Abgeordneten und dem
eu-direktor von Transparency
International 19.30 geht es los auf
Youtube Facebook und in der ZDF heute
App letzten Mittwoch startete eine der
größten Razzien in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik gegen die
reichsbürgerszene das Beschäftigte heute
in Sondersitzungen den Bundestag die 25
Festgenommenen um einen adligen
Unternehmer hatten wohl das Ziel die
staatliche Ordnung zu beseitigen unter
ihnen sind eine ehemalige
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete Soldaten und
Polizisten und einige von ihnen an
Waffen geschult und offenbar
gewaltbereit aus Berlin berichtet Karl
Hinterleitner
radziel in ganz Deutschland Österreich
und Italien heute beschäftigen sich
damit erstmals die deutschen
Parlamentarier sie und das wofür sie
stehen wollte das rechte Netzwerk
stürzen ich glaube dass man nach dem
Sturm auf das amerikanische Parlament
am 6 Januar 2021 ganz klar sehen muss
das ist Menschen gibt die freiheitliche
Demokratien zu Fall bringen wollen und
dagegen muss ich ein wehrhafter
Rechtsstaat
zur Wehr setzen in Berlin ging es heute
um die Konsequenzen eine davon die
systematische Entwaffnung der
sogenannten Reichsbürger doch über das
Wie gibt es die Sense in der Koalition
wir werden das Waffenrecht verschärfen
dass die Feinde der Demokratie ist viel
schwerer haben an Waffen zu kommen das
Waffenrecht erlaubt schon heute eine
Entziehung waffenrechtliche Erlaubnisse
bei reichsbürgern Reichsbürger haben
typischerweise keine waffenrechtliche
Zuverlässigkeit und deswegen braucht es
kein schärferes Waffenrecht Einigkeit
dagegen man müsste bei der AFD von der
sich heute niemand äußerte in Zukunft
noch genauer hinschauen wir müssen eben
auch die Rolle der AFD und ihr
gefährliches Spiel mit dem mit der
Zusammenarbeit mit den reichsbürgern
offenlegen die AFD wird zunehmend zu
einem Sammelbecken für radikalisierende
Gruppen ekliger Natur neue Erkenntnis
heute für die Parlamentarier hunderte
waren in die Pläne der Verschwörer
eingeweiht die über gewaltige
Finanzmittel verfügen wir haben Bargeld
im Bereich von über 400.000 Euro
Silbermünzen und Goldmünzen und es soll
auch im Raum stehen dass ein Schließfach
in dem sich eine Goldbarren im Wert von
6 Millionen auf befinden auch ebenfalls
der Gruppierung eventuell zugeordnet
werden können das politische Berlin ist
von den Vorgängen geschockt jetzt
beginnt die parlamentarische
Aufarbeitung also auch in diesem Fall
kommen immer mehr Details ans Licht
theokol in Berlin also nach den ratien
und bekannt gewordenen umsturzplänen wie
ist die politische Aufarbeitung zu
bewerten
nur in jedem Fall ist heute mehr als
deutlich geworden dass die Reichsbürger
von der Politik jetzt äußerst ernst
genommen werden nicht nur weil die Zahl
auf 23.000 stark angestiegen ist nicht
nur weil man Goldbarren im Wert von 6
Millionen Euro gefunden hat sondern weil
die mutmaßlichen Verschwörer schon mehr
als 280 sogenannte Heimatschutz
Kompanien gebildet hatten mit Menschen
die
Verschwiegenheitserklärung
unterschrieben hatten die
bundesinnenministerin will reagieren und
künftig Extremisten leichter aus dem
Beamtenverhältnis entlassen ähnlich wie
das ja schon Baden Württemberg kann mit
einem Verwaltungsakt statt langejähriger
Gerichtsverfahren mehr als Beamter wegen
Volksverhetzung zu einer Freiheitsstrafe
von mindestens sechs Monaten verurteilt
wird der soll automatisch aus dem
öffentlichen Dienst ausschalten und das
Waffenrecht verschärft werden wir haben
es eben gehört dem widerspricht die FDP
ist reiche das geltende Recht konsequent
anzuwenden dennoch ist heute klar
geworden Einsatz noch die Regierung
ändert die Gange hat danke schön Theo
Paul sorry unterbrechen
die
EU-Außenminister stimmten am Nachmittag
für neue Sanktionen gegen Iran die laut
Annalena baerbock auch Verantwortliche
der jüngsten Hinrichtungen treffen heute
wurde bekannt dass gegen einen zweiten
Demonstranten ein Todesurteil
vollstreckt wurde dass iranische Regime
setzt seine brutale Abschreckungspolitik
also weiter fort mit Todesurteilen mit
weiteren wird gerechnet aus Tehran Jörg
Brase
ein Foto vom Hinrichtungsplatz
Sicherheitskräfte im Vordergrund eine
Menschenmenge im Hintergrund kurz darauf
wird mathe-reser Rad öffentlich erhängt
nach einem Schnellverfahren vor Gericht
das Presseportal der iranischen
Justizbehörden dokumentiert den Fall
akribisch für Drachen erwartet im
Internet vor mit seiner Aussage vor
Gericht
mein Hass kam daher dass ich Videos im
Internet gesehen habe wie Basti Leute
schlagen und töten ich habe die Clips
gesehen und gedacht dass sie wahr sind
Menschen Videos der Justizbehörden
sollen zeigen wie ein Mann zwei
Sicherheitsbeamte mit einem Messer
attackiert und angeblich tötet Geschehen
Mitte November nur dreieinhalb Wochen
nach dieser Tat ist der ehemalige Ringer
majid-reser rachnerwart tot die
Botschaft des Regimes ans eigene Volk
ist klar wer immer sich mit Gewalt gegen
uns auflehnt wird dafür büßen wir werden
wenn nötig schnell und ohne Gnade
Handeln ein ähnliches Schicksal droht
nun zunächst 12 weiteren zum Tode
verurteilten ihre Fälle sollen andere
von einer Teilnahme an weiteren
Protesten abschrecken der Sprecher des
iranischen Außenministeriums kann nie
verwerte sich erneut gegen die
Einmischung des Auslands in innere
Angelegenheiten als Reaktion auf die
neuen EU Sanktionen verhängte Iran
seinerseits Strafmaßnahmen gegen
deutsche und andere Europäer ein eher
symbolischer Akt ob die
einschüchterungspolitik beim eigenen
Volk Wirkung zeigt ob sich weniger auf
die Straßen trauen lässt sich im Moment
noch nicht abschätzen
und jetzt schauen wir nach Lateinamerika
genauer nach Peru seit Tagen herrscht
Ausnahmezustand im erntenstart mit Toten
mit Verletzten die Anhänger des
abgesetzten und verhafteten Präsidenten
fordern dass er freigelassen wird Pedro
castigo links Politiker ehemaliger
Dorfschullehrer vor fünf Tagen wollte er
das Parlament auflösen stattdessen wurde
er das Amtes enthoben und jetzt an der
Spitze Diener bolourate und damit die
erste Präsidentin des Landes über die
Chaos Tage von Peru Christoph röckerath
die Sperren rund ums Parlament in Lima
halten sie nicht auf auch in der letzten
Nacht weichen die Demonstranten erst
zurück als die Polizei gewaltsam
durchgreifen ähnliche Szenen spielen
sich seit Tagen in ganz Peru sie
demonstrieren gegen die Absetzung und
Inhaftierung des bisherigen Präsidenten
petrogastil nach zahlreichen
Korruptionsvorwürfen und Krisen hatte
dieser Mitte letzter Woche versucht mit
der Auflösung des Parlaments seiner
Absetzung durch ein Misstrauensvotum
zuvorzukommen vergeblich die bisherige
Vizepräsidentin Dina Boulevard hat als
erste Frau die Macht in Peru übernommen
in Anbetracht der Proteste verspricht
sie nun aber vorgezogene Neuwahlen
ich habe beschlossen mit dem Kongress
eine Einigung zu erzielen so dass wir
die allgemeinen Wahlen vorziehen können
auf den April 2024
seit Jahren kommt Peru nicht zur Ruhe
als Linke Hoffnungsträger und
Quereinsteiger war Castillo vor
anderthalb Jahren überraschend zum
Präsidenten gewählt worden doch seine
Amtszeit ist geprägt von Machtkämpfen
mit dem Parlament und Korruptionsaffären
rund 70 Minister verschleißt er in nur
18 Monaten am Ende lehnen rund 2/3 der
Peruaner den Präsidenten ab
die politische Krise kommt für das Land
zu uns Zeit Peru leidet unter der
schlimmsten Dürre seit Jahrzehnten die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung ist von
Ernährungsunsicherheit betroffen und
auch das facht jetzt die Wut vieler an
die große Hoffnungen in die Politik
gesetzt hatten
zurück nach Deutschland ein tödlicher
Busunfall in der Hauptstadt steht
stellvertretend für die Misere vieler
deutscher Rettungsdienste in Berliner
Fall dauerte es am Samstag viel zu lang
bis Rettungswagen am Unfallort eintrafen
fehlendes Personal und Notrufe die
eigentlich keine sind nur ein Teil des
Problems jetzt schlägt ein Bündnis Alarm
und sieht die Politik in der Pflicht
Markus groß berichtet
tragischer Unfall am Wochenende in
Berlin ein BVG-Bus erfasst zwar
Jugendliche eine 15-jährige stirbt als
der Notruf eingeht ist im gesamten
Stadtgebiet kein Rettungswagen frei erst
20 Minuten später treffen die Sanitäter
am Unfallort ein immer wieder kommt es
zu Verzögerungen Berlins Feuerwehr fast
täglich im Ausnahmezustand
wir haben zu wenig Rettungswagen es
gelingt uns auch aufgrund der Personal
angespannten personalsituationen die
Rettungswagen die wir eigentlich
benötigen nicht auf die Straße zu
bringen wir müssen rein rechnerisch 140
Rettungswagen täglich auf die Straße
bringen und das schaffen wir nicht der
Rettungsdienst in Deutschland überlastet
die Probleme seit langem bekannt
gestiegende Einsatzzahlen darunter viele
Fahrten ohne wirkliche Notfälle
Personalmangel vor allem bei den
notfallsanitätern und überlastete
Notaufnahmen Rettungswagen warten oft
Stunden um ihre Patienten zu übergeben
das läuft in eine Katastrophe wir werden
in der Zukunft wenn wir jetzt nicht
ändern nicht mehr genug Rettungswagen
auf der Straße haben um jeden einen
anzubieten und dann werden Sie entweder
warten oder wir werden Zustände haben wo
sie alleine in einen Krankenhaus
gefahren müssen um eine Versorgung zu
bekommen Bund und Länder hätten die
Probleme bislang kaum angepackt Reformen
würden diskutiert aber nicht umgesetzt
Mahnwache gestern Nachmittag vor dem
Roten Rathaus Berliner Feuerwehrleute
fordern schnelle Hilfe ein flammender
Protest gegen die hohe Arbeitsbelastung
Rettung vorerst nicht in Sicht
wir machen weiter mit dem Sport hier
heute ist ja noch mal Ruhetag bei der WM
aber morgen morgen geht es ums erste
Finaltickets
spielen Argentinien in Kroatien
gegeneinander die Argentinier letztmalig
2014 gegen Deutschland im Endspiel die
Kroaten vor vier Jahren gegen Frankreich
nun für beide die neue Chance auf Titel
Kurs zu bleiben im Mittelpunkt zwei
alsters
Lionel Messi gegen Luka Modric Duell
zweier Weltfußballer für einen wohl der
letzte Auftritt auf der größten
Fußballbühne Coach scaloni hat Respekt
vor dem Kroaten der 2018 im Gruppenspiel
gegen Argentinien traf
er ist ein Vorbild für viele nicht nur
als Spieler auch als Mensch
ich denke jeder der den Fußball liebt
möchte solche Spieler sehen
Lionel Messi will in fünften Anlauf den
Titel der einzige der ihm noch fehlt
vielleicht entscheiden am Ende die
Torhüter über den Finaleinzug sowohl
Argentiniens Emiliano Martinez als auch
Kroatiens Dominik liwakovic glänzten in
Katar im Elfmeterschießen
ja und dann Mittwochabend live hier bei
uns im ZDF Titelverteidiger Frankreich
gegen den Favoritenschreck Marokko ein
Duell mit einer besonderen Prägung und
einer engen Verbundenheit
Jubel auf den Champs Elysées
französische und marokkanische Fans am
Wochenende feierten sie noch gemeinsam
den Einzug ins Halbfinale ihrer
Mannschaften die nun gegeneinander
antreten werden manch einer spricht von
einem Bruder Duell so spielen mbappé
Frankreich Stürmer und Hakimi Marokkos
Verteidiger zusammen bei PSG sind
befreundet und nicht nur die beiden
verbindet viel
das wird schon besonders es Leben enorm
viele Marokkaner in Frankreich das wird
eine Riesenparty und dann haben wir
Spieler ja auch schon einiges zusammen
erlebt raggi Marokko so wie viele seiner
Spieler sind in Frankreich geboren
unterdessen Protektorat Marokko einst
stand nun beißen sich die Atlas Löwen
durch was sie vom Favoriten trennt ihr
Marktwert deutlich unter Frankreich und
auch Anzahl an Titeln doch in der Gunst
der Fans liegen sie beide gleich auf es
lebe marokko ist Liebe Frankreich möge
der beste gewinnen Außenseiter gegen
Titelverteidiger es wird ein Abend
voller Emotionen
mein heißer Tanz Mittwochabend hier bei
uns ich tippe auf Marokko Argentinien im
Endspiel
danke Christin eins kann ich Ihnen schon
mal mitgeben ziehen Sie sich warm an
weitere Wetter Details hat gleich
mehr zur Brüsseler Korruptionsaffäre um
21:45 Uhr im heute journal mit Christian
Sievers das war es von uns bis morgen
und noch eine entspannten Abend machen
sie es gut
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in den nächsten
Tagen sieht es nach einer gefährlichen
grenzwetterlage aus eisige Luft kommt
aus dem Norden und relativ milde Luft
aus dem Südwesten und dort wo sich diese
Luftmassen treffen ja da gibt es
Schneefälle und vor allem gefrierenden
Regen erstmal die kommende Nacht im
Südwesten klartis auf Temperaturen gehen
bis auf -16° zurück -17 Richtung
Vogtland und ganze Norden fällt etwas
Schnee hier auch Glätte und der Schnee
im Osten im Erzgebirge zieht allmählich
ab morgen dann sonniges Wetter in der
Mitte und nach Südosten hin ganz im
Norden weiterhin viele Wolken und
Schneefälle ja und ähm Südwesten kommt
zum späten Nachmittag und abends neuer
Schneefall auf das gehört schon zu
diesem zu dieser warmen Luft die sich da
auf dem Weg macht bei -5 bis +2 Grad ja
und wir schauen noch auf den Mittwoch
noch einmal genauer in der Mitte also
Richtung Main Schneefälle ganz im Süden
Regen oder zwischen gefrierender Regen
der für große Glätte sorgen wird bei
höchsten Temperaturen von -4 bis plus 5
Grad und damit ein schöner Abend